Perrie pi is a big ol meanie Logan Paul
defends himself and much more
information coming up I'm poppy Harlow
and you're watching boom
[Music]
good evening I'm poppy Harlow
you're watching prio news the most in
sight as you may have heard PewDiePie
got into trouble in the media recently
hey I don't even care that it was a
deep-fried mean the fact that he posted
it speaks volumes I feel like I'm
probably better off not talking about
this but I want to share my thoughts I
didn't know much about Demi I only
really just played her video game a few
years ago and I realized that it's for
kids she clearly has a very very young
audience me to see that she's messing
with drugs I just thought what an idiot
I'm not the greatest role model but at
least I've never done anything
straight-out illegal so I thought well
you know it's just fun to make fine to
just make fun of it and I realized now
no no it wasn't because a lot of people
seem to doubt my sincerity I guess in
some way just to give context I was 5
a.m. in the morning sometimes my dogs
wake me up really early and this has
nothing to do with anything
basically I saw the meme it made me
laugh and I posted it on like Twitter I
went to sleep two hours I woke up and a
lot of people were really upset to be
honest I didn't get it I didn't get it
at all I'm not the one doing drugs what
the heck did I do the meme is so ironic
and so stupid talking about like like a
boss I was like she's still alive what's
the problem if anything this is a way to
snap out of it like yeah you were an
idiot so the fact that people came after
me I was just I was really trying to
understand why so I read up on addiction
I try to decipher in between the you
should burn in fire
suggests cuz it also a lot of people are
saying that I was making fun of mental
health which no that wasn't the case at
all I was making fun of Demi and her
poor choices cuz a lot of people were
like will you talked about mental help a
few days ago in a video you're searching
hypocrite I wasn't doing that I was
making fun of Demi for her board
decision I realized and I learned that
ostracizing and shaming is the last
thing an addict needs to recover because
that's just going to make them more
likely to relapse and fall back into
that behavior what an addict need is
support and help from friends and family
and I think the public as well and I
also learned that this is her second
time she's dealt with drugs I just
thought I'm really just kicking on
someone that's on their complete lowest
I get why people are upset this was
wrong for me to do it was a bad thing to
do I don't think it was the worst thing
in the world but it wasn't a nice thing
I can definitely say that so I thought
okay you know what I'll just delete it
and I'll apologize sincerely and that
should be it how foolish I am I always
get people telling me stop apologizing
you idiot what are you doing you're just
making things worse
any time you apologize to these people
they don't care and they're just gonna
shame you even more I think that's what
happened
BBC posted about it NBC posted about it
BuzzFeed I think the BuzzFeed
journalists on her Twitter call it the
hell fire or something like that like
this is the hell we live in
it's like cheese but I feel like if I
think I've done something wrong I
shouldn't have the ego or the strategy
to just say no it's better if I don't
apologize a lot of people were saying
that anyone could have posted this meme
and no one would bat an eye and I I
think there is some truth to that I find
it interesting how you have someone
that's a role model to a lot of kids you
make a message about how much better you
are now and then you just fall back into
the same pain and somehow I'm the bad
role
model in this situation huh I'm the
villain for just posting a meme about it
it doesn't really make sense to me and
I'm not attacking her I'm just saying
that a lot of people were saying that
it's not her fault
for her addiction it's an addiction she
can't control it and I agree she
shouldn't be shamed because of an
addiction but I also don't think babying
people will help either saying that it's
completely out of someone's control is
also saying that it's not up to them to
recover from it it's like saying anyone
that recovered from addiction didn't do
it from their own work and will it's
just a completely random ven which
doesn't make any sense it's always been
a meme on this channel that anything I
say will be picked up on the media and I
feel like this was just a testimony of
that mean like that's it's a truth
essentially anything I say will be
highlighted they will jump on any reason
to put down my name because if they
really cared about these issues about
addiction they would go after the people
that that shed a light on it in a
positive way not the ones that try and
ridicule it I don't know I don't care
moving on I wasn't gonna talk about this
but it came on today and I watched it I
thought it was so crazy that I had to
talk about it
kz9 said there's an interview with Logan
Paul and man I want to like you Logan I
swear but you making it really hard and
I find this super interesting cos KZ and
Logan are very similar personalities
they're all about pushing the edge of
living life to the fullest but their
drives are just completely opposite I
think it means falling into the social
medium machine over the past four years
building an audience garnering false
power through views which equates to
money which equates to against success
and then essentially losing it all
overnight becoming the most hated man in
the world
in the snap of a finger so the hyperbole
every single time the most hated man
Casey asked lo at Logan about this
documentary that he's filming and about
the whole incident is this a fluff piece
to make people feel better about Logan
Paul no no not at all this it's it's
from making content throughout the years
I try to be as unbiased as possible and
this documentary is going to be as
unbiased as possible but it's me who
makes it okay great
I'm sure we very unbiased think people
should can or will sympathize with me
let's be honest Casey like let's be
honest Casey I don't know Marcus I see
through your social training Logan when
you put out content like that do you
realize the age of your audience it's
odd because Michael I'm 22 years old
it's not like I don't know why but
whenever I see small things like this I
know I'm nitpicking it feels
disingenuous is it not premature like it
before you can tell a redemption story
there has to be an act of redemption
true what is the act of redemption bin
for Logan Paul it's it's not been done
yet
that's Logan is talking about how this
documentary is going to be his
redemption story because people love it
a redemption story people told me this
verbatim so many times that you
shouldn't you need to do your redemption
you need to film a documentary people
told me this many times that's how
you'll do your comeback and people are
telling Logan the same thing and that's
why it's doing this documentary just
like people told me after the wall
street journal that I need to do a
charity for Jewish charities or
something like that and I said no not
because I don't want to because but
because it will seem like the most
disingenuous thing ever you're not doing
it because you want to you're doing it
to save your brand and people are smart
enough to see through those things
the rat Casey has Logan about the red
you know as soon as this forest incident
he tastes the rat or whatever why what
was up with that yeah the rat was that
was me becoming obsessed with the idea
of being a villain I just I made the
conscious decision I'm gonna I'm gonna
be the guy they think I am I can
actually relate to Logan here a lot of
times after all the scandals I've been
through I question my own morals I
question why do I keep ending up in
these situations and a lot of times I
find the answer to be I am genuinely a
bad person I do die I genuinely think it
a lot of times not all the times but I
think the difference is I'm not trying
to make other people think I'm a good
person
I can make content and I have been for
four years for four years making people
laugh smile believing themselves making
them believe that they can accomplish
their goals even if they're from a small
town in Ohio I've been making videos for
eight years I just want to show people
that you can make it even if you're just
from a small town in Sweden what are you
saying to use that same pretext as sort
of justification for you know killing a
rat or why didn't kill the rat just shut
up it doesn't matter at this point don't
defend these things it's the same with
me when I drop the n-bomb a lot of
people were like he said it to another
person and I always want to say no no
one heard me say it but I'm not gonna
use that defense because it doesn't
matter that's not what people took out
of it some of the other more
controversial sensational things you've
done yeah running around Japan wearing
silly outfits yeah so that Union
sensitive to culture apparently for some
reason
Casey calls Casey calling Logan
culturally insensitive it's the most
upsetting thing ever for him I want to
address this cuz I'm not gonna lie this
is the the hardest thing about all this
is I think being perceived as culturally
insensitive
I'm not gonna lie but the hardest thing
out of all this it's the fact that you
just called me culturally insensitive
that's okay I are we expected to believe
that or as far as the outfits go they
were on sale at a store the outfits were
on sale on their store so then it's okay
right next to the temple that we were at
for tourists do we not buy the outfits
maybe he just doesn't understand what it
is there's a difference between
culturally insensitive and insensitive
but it also doesn't matter and you don't
seem to understand why one is offensive
anyway so I'm vegan now I think the most
important thing to take out of this
video is this I'm vegan now I'm vegan
now I'm a good person why do you think
you being vegan is relevant to anything
doing what you want to do to achieve
your goals which is all like I said it's
always been that but all that stuff is
overlooked when you make mistake or I
can agree again with Logan here he's
done good I mean I don't agree with it
but he thinks he's done good like
inspiring kids and I can relate to that
I think I've done a lot of positive for
in with my channel as well that never
gets highlighted but I don't feel the
need to constantly tell people like I'm
a good person look I do it done all
these things
I don't know these charities I don't
know these things look I'm a good person
that shouldn't be your mission to keep
reminding people so then Logan talks
about how it led up to all this scandal
like he was just constantly making
videos and not thinking what he was
doing we got so caught up in creating
that we did not stop to think about what
we were making and whether or not it was
right because it you make it you put it
out we were on autopilot essentially
which is it's it's extremely dangerous
when you're broadcasting to an audience
of five to seven million people every
day and so there was no thinking there
was it was create content
create content create content not okay
hey take a step back slow down
breathe do you believe that or is that
[ __ ] because if that's if that
mission is the same as this this
momentum this autopilot where's the
distinction between wanting to do good
and wanting to you know looking for
sensationalism that will drive clicks
I'm not I'm not sure I understand the
question that's such a great question
I'm not I'm not sure I understand Chris
hey this is too much of a mumbo-jumbo
he's saying that if you're just on
autopilot and you're not thinking about
what you're doing how can they you say
that you care about spreading a positive
message and not just caring about
sensationalism I understand I understand
okay I can go on pick details whatever
you should watch you interview it's
interesting a lot of people gave Casey
or doing this I think it's good to
create a dialogue it's a shame how
people are so militant towards people
they don't like that they won't even
talk to them because that's really how
you create division more than anything
which is leads to more hate
I think is he's doing a noble thing but
the final point I find hilarious because
Casey praises Logan's anti-suicide video
that the video he did after the whole
thing and the response from Logan it's
just that video I think had a very
important message behind it was a I
liked that video I tweeted that I liked
that video I get for it but did it show
you sort of the demonstrate to you that
your channel is capable of so much more
and your reach is capable and your voice
is capable of so much more than just in
socialism views yes did it change you
away from sensationalism and views that
what is a question his answer it's it's
the most viewed suus anti-suicide PSA
ever it's the most viewed ever
I am so great I have the most viewed PSA
anti-suicide video ever I don't really
want Lowen to come back but I don't
think he can until he's completely
honest because people are constantly
going to be skeptical especially at this
point I think this entire interview
Logan is trying to give the answer that
he thinks KZ wants and my tip for Logan
unsolicited advice would be question
yourself why these titles are important
to you oh I'm vegan or you can't call me
culturally insensitive and why you care
that your video anti PSA has the most
views why is that important to you and
I'm asking you right honestly is it to
reach more people or is it because you
like things to be big because we've seen
only evidence for that so far so that's
all people are gonna see your intention
might be different but I doubt it
next news twitch added gifts is that in
gifts that's crazy
alright we're out of time
[Music]